[Music]
so we saw that you guys like the
previous video on rage moments and of
course I figured out that had to get
this one going 10 rage moments was
something but why not go further beyond
that for this edition of top rage
moments we're going to be bringing you
not just the main character moments this
time I decided to feature even side
characters as well hey who said that
only the main characters can have
intense moments of rage and emotion in
anime hey without further ado here we go
strap your seatbelts on and get ready
for the ride
we begin things with a classic Gohan's
rage moment during the cell arc things
take a turn for the worse in sales
battle against go harmed realizing that
nothing seems to be working as far as
awakening Gohan's latent powers sale
decides to create smaller blue versions
of himself the sell juniors get the job
done with ease being more or less
perfect imitations of sales powers
despite Gohan's anger it still wasn't
enough though the breaking point comes
when Android 16 gets crushed by cell
after words of encouragement realizing
that it's fine to go wild and fight to
defend his loved ones
Gohan reaches his limit and creates a
moment that would soon become a
trademark of this arc the death of
Android 16 enrages Gohan to the point of
unlocking Super Saiyan 2 to say that
Gohan became a very angry is a gross
understatement you can just feel the
emotional outpouring watching this seed
and you can tell that he really had
enough and that cell is gonna pay you
quickly defeat cell juniors with his
newfound power but a battle with cell is
far from over you'll just have to
re-watch this arc for that
[Music]
and number nine we have Oscar in end of
evangelion
for much of the event galleon series I'd
say that Oscar got the char
she may be one of the forerunners in one
of the most long-lasting waifu wars in
anime history but her actual onscreen
performance is let's just say it's
lackluster she does have a moment of
glory in end of evangelion after
overcoming her mental hurdles and
reaching a state of full synchronization
with Eva Oh - with that she proceeds to
do battle with MP Eva's and manages to
win in a commanding victory that we
haven't seen out of her in episodes at
least our first and last the show had to
end for her and she gets pierced by the
spear of Longinus but even as she goes
down her rage seemingly wills her on
before she gets put down for good but
don't tell me that the preceding rage
moment was not something that stayed in
your minds for a very very long time up
next in eighth place is connect ease
rage moment against Nishio despite the
impression that his gentle appearance at
first glance may give knowing the nature
of Tokyo ghoul would clue everyone in
that Carnegie would have one of those
moments right up his sleeve we didn't
have to wait long to see the inevitable
as Carnegie unleashes his rage and to
Nishio in Episode two certainly not one
of the scenes for the faint-hearted as
we're all gifted with some of the more
egregious censoring on anime courtesy of
the negative colors just by the blu-ray
they say nonetheless the moment still
remains a memorable one thanks to
Carnegie's voice acting the way his car
guna appears and the overall violence
that the resulting beatdown entails
[Music]
of characters who just simply ooze
badass an edge you'd expect the series
most impactful rage moment to come from
someone like alucard
or anderson however in my opinion the
most impact for one of them belongs to
serous Victoria I think that it's the
flashback beforehand that and the fact
that saris one of the sweetest and most
pure hearted characters in the series
was responsible for one of the most
intense rage moments in the show it kind
of caught me by surprise actually
thanks to pip sacrificing the losing
fight against Zoran blitz saris gets
saved but Zoran resumes his relentless
assault after the Millennium vampire
insults pip Sera's decides to finally
drink pips blood this lets her restore
herself and to unload a can of
ass-kicking ultimately taking down Zoran
you really shouldn't have insulted pip
Gintama comes in at number six with
Kagura seen in the fight against Alberto
need a quick way to get your shown in
main character riled up and unlock a
hidden power harming his or her friends
seems to be the surefire way to do this
in this episode Alberto quite easily
handles Kagura and shinpachi
coming out with a brand new slashes
smile and a look fitting of a horror
movie monster kagu returns the tides on
him and the battle takes a sudden turn
Kagura finally awakens to the impulse of
a yato blood however it all seems to
naught as Alberto finally contains
Kagura or so he thought after a
jump-scare Kagura quickly resumes work
and leaves even the spectators wondering
if that's really the car guru that
everybody knew it's rare for rage to
consume someone like Kagura but when it
does and said so beyond her limits the
results ain't pretty
you expected a series like Hajime no
Ippo to have one of these and here it is
coming up at number five is the cameras
shining moment coming into the fight
against the undefeated hawk Nakamura
seems have found his perfect match
finally the camera gets paired with
someone just as loud and boisterous as
him and his American counterpart Hawk
control walk the walk when it comes to
settling things in the ring in terms of
intensity Hawk has no peer
but it's Nakamura finally tapping into
that intensity and rage that keeps him
in the game and ultimately gets him on
top talk about beating someone at their
own game at the fights darkest moment
it's the cameras unstoppable rage that
allows him to finally turn the tides the
blue eyes say it all the intensity has
been turned up to such an extent that it
allows him to finally settle the score
and put end to the undefeated streak of
Brian Hawk the scene featuring decisive
punches fueled by his complete rage is
something that Hajime no Ippo fans will
remember forever
your LOI
[Music]
they say never to play with fire an MV
learns that lesson with the first-hand
experience in one of the plentiful
scenes that helped cement Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood as the
highest-rated anime on my anime list
sorry
interspecies reviewers fans as if I was
debating if I should choose this moment
or the batter with lust I think that
this fight just gets a slight edge
because of its pure raw emotion it's in
this fight against MV where you can
fully see what extent a pissed-off
mustang can do the death glare the
kernel gives to MV is just telling and
he proceeds to deliver an execution
battering MV with snap after snap of his
fire powers the result a completely
charred homunculus that's utterly
helpless against Mustang is this revenge
for Mays use who knows
[Music]
need any proof to see how badass white
bid is and that he's a person that you
would never ever want to piss off a
canoe gets a first-hand experience of it
in the seed white beard appears behind
the Admiral his towering and shadowy
presence overwhelming a canoe has safely
heard boss music and at that point he
would have known that he was screwed y
bydd then proceeds to show Aquino who's
the boss by delivering a devastating
beatdown absolutely wrecking him and
showing everyone the difference between
an admiral and a young KO Howard dyeing
white beard manages to do this is simply
amazing a guy knew having survived the
ordeal is an even more amazing feat by
itself and it had people calling
[ __ ]
[Music]
voila rap is Naruto Shippuden
thanks to Obito it's no secret that
Obito really loved rim now what does a
man do when he sees his former friend
killed a girl and is left with nothing
to lose
for Obito the answer is simple be
completely consumed with rage unleash it
and go down the path of villainy for
good seeing the sight of rin getting
killed by Kakashi was enough to make
Obito snap unable to accept any of this
the ninja trembles in anger and takes
his frustrations on the Hidden Mist
ninjas the slaughter that follows is
merely a preview of the emotional
turmoil that Obito must be having at
this moment granted the Hidden Mist
ninjas were obviously fodder but you can
feel the emotion with each of obito's of
frustrated punches and attacks he became
a one-man army in his own right and in
that state absolutely nothing can stop
him
attack on titan + rage moment alright
time to have an arrow moment capping off
the list mm-hmm not really
rage and fury aren't exactly the traits
that you would associate with Levi but
attack on Titans no regrets OVA showed
us one of the moments of peak rage and
it came from none other than the
supposed calm and stoic ly vibe
seeing those dead people who meant so
much to him completely set him off and
Levi quickly went to work the only way
he can wick massacre and decimation of
Titans it's rare that you see Levi with
this much emotion but there it is you
could also tell that why he massacred
the Titan he was seemingly prolonging
the bloodbath prolonging the pain as if
trying to torture the hapless monster
and making it feel every bit of his
emotional scars
looks like Levi and Eren aren't too
different after all
[Music]
and that just about wraps it up for this
week do the entries get your blood
boiling which among these rage moments
is your favorite I'd love to hear your
thoughts and you guys know what to do if
you found this list fun and interesting
I would suggest giving this video a
thumbs up and subscribing to Vinnie -
for more similar content in the weeks to
come
trust me we've got loads more up our
sleeves
[Music]